are you I am ready to get into the
holiday spirit
I [ __ ] love Christmas Christmas is
the holiday that can pull out all the
stubs like I've been waiting on you to
make this dish right here and you come
out tasting like my body is ready my
soul is ready I want to like put
Christmas lights everywhere and scream
to the world we're so ready
[Music]
I don't know this looks like a like a
weird Christmas cookie version of a
chicken potpie it's a gift from Santa
hmm
dang that's hard this is what I always
wanted Christmas to taste like this is
like 80% reason no sense not this kind
of taste like I just took a bite out of
like a piece of chapstick it tastes like
a giant mound of the inside of a Fig
Newton
[Music]
is it is KK hope to be scared oh no now
this is rump it feels like itself dude
something just Oh gummy bears I'm eating
wrong and I'm okay with it I think it
just tastes like sweet which is amazing
it's like a dream good stuff man no
happy hour for me today
[Music]
this looks like a pierogi it kind of
smells like a chicken potpie on the
inside it's filled with potatoes corrine
cheese I call it that way
five bucks with this I'm gonna eat this
whole thing I would eat this on
prescription pill oh he ate this every
day
[Music]
this is Purdy he's beautiful it looks
fancy but it also looks like I'm not
gonna like it just looks like scarier on
the way down that looks at fish to me oh
it's so squishy sounds disgusting oh I
should not have smelled it I don't want
a problem with this
[Music]
yeah oh my god oh my god I don't like
this it
in Japan they eat like a fried chicken
and Chris escape is that like is that
really a thing like in Japan like KFC
yeah oh of course we can see I would
love to have KFC for Christmas there is
no way I was expecting
KFC when I came in here today I think it
was a Christmas miracle oh this is
Christmas Canton booze and fried chicken
on Christmas that's amazing what are we
doing in America right I feel like
everything looked pretty Christmasy but
some of the things just were not what I
expected
it was definitely surprising to see
things that like I recognize and have
had before but it would never associate
with Christmas at the Japanese
absolutely yeah I mean I could do that
like one tomorrow no cooking just call
KFC call the colonel he's got you I
haven't done kiss scene a long time it's
actually better than I remember
[Music]